Good, tout est tout est en marche. Tout
fonctionne parfait. Good. Donc euh
bienvenue à cette vidéo aussi qu'on va
parler de atteindre ses objectifs. Puis
comment atteindre ses objectifs ? Ça ne
va rien changer.
Donc
un petit opérier pour pour
commencer. Donc sachez que ça fait deux
fois que je fais cette vidéolà.
Je l'ai viens de la filmer. Ça a pris un
30 35 minutes puis je me suis rendu
compte que
le son avait pas enregistré. Là, j'ai
bien fait attention de savoir de de
remarquer si le son avait recordé et
effectivement le son record. Donc
good euh donc directement c'est parti.
Ça on va aller skipper. Good. Donc je
vais mettre mon image ici. Donc en ça
veut dire en cinq parties. Donc on va
parler du problème, on va parler du
syndrome du bonheur différé, euh comment
jouer sa vie, le vrai déclic puis des
petites questions pour conclure. Euh
good donc
ça on passer rapidement là-dessus mais
en gros là qu'est-ce que je voulais
aborder là ? que tu fixer les objectifs
dans vie si tu es tout le temps en mode
je veux atteindre ces objectifs là puis
quand je vais avoir ces objectifs là
d'atteint je vais être heureux
ça c'est le gros problème. Donc
j'ai réalisé que j'avais pas de problème
de motivation, j'avais un problème de
structure. C'est quoi ton prochain
objectif déjà ? Donc
si tu tout le temps un mode, j'ai un
objectif, c'est ça le problème. Si tu
tout le temps un mode, j'ai un objectif,
quand je l'atteint, je vais être
heureux, il est là le problème.
Donc
surtout dans la culture
entrepreneuriale, il y a vraiment cette
culture là de tout le temps work puis
genre grind puis toujours
tu es jamais assez comme mais ça c'est
vraiment hyper toxique sur le long terme
quand tu es jamais satisfait de ce que
tu vis puis tu es tout le temps en mode
juste uniquement focus sur l'objectif en
tant que tel puis quand tuas l'objectif
là tu vas être heureux puis ça c'est le
problème qu'on aime pas en
entrepreneuriat
donc surtout dans la vingtaine on On est
beaucoup en mode il faut que tu gr au
max puis faut que tu tu vives au tu
travailles puis genre e pas grave tu vas
commencer à vivre plus tard comme ton
toi du futur va te remercier ça 100 %
d'accord avec ça c'est super important
mais il faut pas le faut pas idéaliser
uniquement ça dans sa vie
on va ça va être ça le sujet de la vidéo
aujourd'hu
fait ça maintenant on on check sur les
podcasts et c'est quoi Qui euh c'est qui
c'est quoi qui en ressort le plus ? Ben
tu sais sur LinkedIn maintenant ça va
être genre quelqu'un qui va partir qui
va dire que à 22 ans il a bâtu un empire
puis il a fait des millions quelun au
stat qui a fait ça. Puis l'affaire
toxique làdedans, c'est que nous on va
se comparer à lui. On va dire je suis
pas assez. Lui il vit sa vie tu sais.
Lui il lui c'est l'idéal tu sais. Lui il
a fait des millions. Lui
je veux être comme lui. Puis quand je
vais être comme lui là je vais commencer
à rire.
podcast travaille plus fort, vis plus
haut sleepless full fier d'avoir dormi
5h cette nuit puis toutes les autres
soirs ce nuit, j'avais un average de 5
6h par nuit de de sommeil
al sur le long terme c'est t sais c'est
comme tellement focus sur l'objectif en
en précisément que tu oublies de vivre,
tu oublies de d'apprécier les moments tu
sais dans travaille plus fort atteint
tes goals puis là tu seras heureux un
coup que tu atteintes goals là tu vas
être heureux mais c'est pas ça qui va te
rendre heureux littéralement pu ça en ce
il y a personne qui en question tu sais
c'est comme c'est dit à qui tu sais euh
si je fais référence au livre et si
l'entrepreneuriat rendez fou de là j'ai
juste les noms de famille j'ai oublié le
nom le prénom
c'est ça donc mais très bon liv pour
tout ce qui est mindset pas mindset
entrepreneurial c'est plus au niveau de
la psychologie euh comment les
entrepreneurs c'est difficile pour eux
d'être
prenant seul au sommet beaucoup de
pression puis comment que il ont ils
peuvent pas en parler aux autres
à risque de se faire comme juger comme
étant pas assez solide euh pour la
business.
Donc très bon livre. Donc c'est là qui
nous mène à 72 % des entrepreneurs sont
affectés par des problèmes de santé
mentale comparativement à 48 % de la
population générale. Donc c'est la même
réalité mais moins intense parce que
les entrepreneurs sont jamais assez.
Il y a cette culture là de tu es jamais
assez, tu dois toujours faire plus
puis c'est là que tu vas commencer à
vivre quand tu vas avoir atteint tes
objectifs.
C'est pas qu' sont plus fragiles, c'est
qu'il se mettent tellement pas sur ses
épaules.
il vise tellement haut
puis au final
c'est parfait de viser haut tu sais
genre l'expression c'est vise la lune
puis dans le pas des cas ben tu tomber
étoil tu sais genre parfait mais c'est
pas juste ça
euh puis les entrepreneurs les plus
successful sont pas eux qui sont le plus
épanalouis nécessairement tu sais parce
que ce qu'on voit ça va être les revenus
la croissance les équipes reconnaissance
et cetera. Mais ce qui se passe
vraiment, c'est énormément d'anxiété,
d'isolement, l'insatisfaction chronique,
tu sais, c'est tout le temps en mode je
veux plus, je veux plus, je veux plus,
tu sais. Donc ça c'est hyper toxique tu
sais puis le masque il coûte vraiment
cher, tu sais.
Ils veulent pas demander de l'aide, ils
vont pas montrer leur stress parce que
ils veulent pas se sentir faible. Ils
veulent pas montrer aux autres que eux
autres aussi ils vivent du stress. Euh
c'est en mode genre je vais performer
jusqu'à temp que ça marche. L'énergie
qui devrait aller dans le vrai travail
va dans la façade. Donc ça va être
vraiment de tu vas oublier toutes tes s
toute ton intérieur, ton anxiété et
cetera puis tu vas tout mettre ça dans
le travail en mode un jour je vais être
heureux.
Mais by the way c'est pas un jour tu vas
être heureux, c'est tu décèdes
aujourd'hui d'être heureux tu sais.
Donc fais en sorte que aujourd'hui tu
sois heureux puis tu apprécies ton
process.
C'est ça qui lui mène au bonheur
différé. Le nombre du bonheur différé
c'est de dire
quand je vais avoir atteint X, quand je
quand je vais avoir atteint peu importe,
là je vais être heureux là je vais
commencer à vivre ma vie là ça va être
la vraie vie. Là, je vais être bien, tu
sais.
Mais
spoiler alert,
tu vas
avoir tout le temps d'autres choses. Tu
seras pas heureux plus quand tu v
atteindre ça. On va voir plus tard, mais
faut que tu apprécies le process, faut
que tu apprécies aujourd'hui, tu sais.
Parce que pourquoi atteindre tes
objectifs ne te rend pas plus heureux ?
On va voir ça DR ici. Donc c'est tout le
temps une carotte qui se déplace. Tu
sais comme l'analogie d'avoir une paille
avec une carotte en avant de toi. Tu je
vais avoir la carotte, je vais avoir la
carotte. Fa que tu avances, tu avances,
tu avances puis tu l' puis il y a tout
le temps de carotte après. Tu sais fait
c'est comme on voit ici tu sais ton
premier client, tu es comme je vais avir
mon premier client, je vais être heureux
et après ça e à 100 à 100000 par année
là je vais être bon, je vais pas ouvrir
puis après ça e là j'éis à 100000 mais
là il faut que j' une meilleure équipe
que ça. Mon équipe pas sa coche. Quand
je une bonne équipe là on va être bon.
Là on est on veut aller à 1 million, on
va 1 million che d'affaires puis là je
vais être heureux
après ça c'est ça toute ta vie la ligne
d'arrivée elle existe pas puis chaque
arrivé c'est un nouveau départ
automatiquement ça qui fait que tu es
jamais heureux pleinement tu sais puis
ton cerveau s'adapte à tout même à tes
succès
fait ce que tu crois c'est quand je vais
attendre X ça va te donner un sentiment
durable sur la satisfaction de il
bonheur tu vas être heureux pour le
reste de ta vie parce que tu as atteint
ton objectif de faire un million de chef
d'affaires. Là, tu vas être heureux pour
le reste de ta vie. Mais c'est pas ça
pas tout parce qu'il va toujours avoir
un autre objectif.
Le cerveau se renormalise tout en
quelques semaines. Tu te redeviens
toujours à ta baseline. Toujours.
Donc si ici on voit la baseline ici la
ligne, ça c'est toujours ta baseline que
tu vas revenir.
Quand tu montes, tuas un objectif,
tu vis la dopamine pendant que tu
montes. Quand tu l'atteins, ça prend
quelques jours, quelques semaines puis
tu redescends. Puis je te rends compte
qu'il y a un autre objectif, ainsi de
suite. Puis tu vas toujours vivre ça
ainsi de suite. Toujours en mode on
monte, on monte, tu l'atteins, tu
redescends un autre objectif, ainsi de
suite. Donc tu vas toujours rester à ta
baseline.
Ton cerveau, il est fait pour survivre.
C'est pour ça que ça fait que tu es pas
heureux parce que ton cerveau,
il est fait pour toujours voir les
problématiques, pour les préchotes, pour
pas se faire euh attaquer ou affecter sa
survie. Parce que dans le monde, quand
tu étais un
tu chasseur, cuilleur, peu importe,
fallait que tu tu as tout le temps
alerte. C'est quoi les problématiques
qui peuvent arriver ? Même si
aujourd'hui tu as eu une belle journée
puis tu as eu plein de nourriture par
exemple tu chassé peu importe là tu as
eu full la nourriture pour la prochaine
semaine ben faut déjà que tu penses à
dans 2 semaines a dans un mois dans 3
mois il y a la là il y a l'hiver s'en
vient je dois je dois je dois me
préparer pour avoir de la nourriture
assez pour quand ça ça va arriver fait
ton cerveau il s'est adapté à être
toujours en mode survie
puis il s'adapte à ce que tu lui donnes.
Donc le cerveau traite les nouvelles
situations comme la nouvelle normale,
un mécanisme de survie pas un défaut, tu
sais. C'est comme c'est ça ce que tu es
rendu à ton niveau, c'est rendu normal.
Si tu es rendu fucking riche puis tu as
tu manges toujours au resto euh puis peu
importe tu voyages 15 fois par année ben
ça ton cerveau il va devenir habitué à
ça.
Puis la dopamine est libérée dans la
dans l'anticipation. Donc quand tu veux
l'atteindre, quand tu travailles pour
l'atteindre, la dopamine est dégagée
déjà fait pas à l'accomplissement.
Ça fait que une boucle sans fin.
Euh donc ta responsabilité c'est juste
de comprendre ça puis de jouer
différemment en fonction de ça. En
fonction de de comprendre comment que ta
dopamine fonctionne puis comment c'est
toxique de réfléchir comme ça.
Tu dois juste prendre ta responsabilité
puis de jouer ta vie différemment
parce que sinon c'est le cycle de l'ego
qui va t'embarquer. Ça va être toujours
l'ego a besoin de validation externe.
Donc toujours se sentir pour se sentir
réel l'ego va toujours avoir besoin de
validation.
Donc des diplômes, chiffres de revenus,
des follower, la recognition
l'ego, il est jamais satisfait parce
qu'il peut pas, il peut pas être dans sa
nature l'ego ne peut pas être satisfait
tout temps, il veut avoir plus parce
qu'il se compare à plus toujours il va
toujour quelquun qui est plus riche que
toi.
objectif qui est piloté par l'ego. Donc
soit que c'est parce que tu as tu l'
avoir un nouveau char, une nouvelle
femme, une nouvelle maison euh tu sais
peu importe quand c'est alimenté par
l'ego dans le fait de vouloir montrer
aux autres,
bah tu vas jamais être satisfait pour
toute ta vie. C'est un c'est continuel.
Donc tu poses un objectif, tu l'atteins,
il y a un vide, c'est quoi le prochain ?
Ainsi de suite. Ça ta vie comme ça.
Pas en faisant plus d'efforts que tu vas
sortir de cette B.
Donc l' veut briller
puis le travail veut durer. Donc l'ut
plus briller,
toujours atteindre plus d'objectif,
toujours être meilleur que les autres.
Plus tu veux prouver, moins tu es
satisfait. Donc si tu as une ambition
qui vraiment de prouver aux autres que
tu es capable de faire ça, tu es capable
d'être big, tu serais jamais satisfait.
Mais si tuas une ambition de construire,
c'est là que la partie solution
embarque. Quand ton ambition est de
construire quelque chose de plus grand,
tu te nourris du processus. Tu as pas
besoin de témoin, tu as pas besoin
d'avoir personne autour de toi pour te
dire que ce que tu fais c'est bien. Puis
tu as pas besoin d'avoir de ça pour
alimenter puis avancer dans ta vie.
C'est là que tu peux durer une vie
entière parce que la motivation est
intrinsèque est pas extrèque.
De la différence les deux
si on fait un petit retour motivation
extrè c'est tuattends d'avoir de quoi en
échange de ton effort que te te que tu
mets fait par exemple tu fais des
efforts pour avoir un diplôme tu tes
devoirs tu tout ça pour avoir ton
diplôme. Motivation extrèque c'est avoir
ton diplôme. motivation intrinsèque, ça
serait apprendre, évoluer,
me bâtir un réseau, des amis,
des apprentissages,
apprendre à me connaître. motivation
intrinsèque à l'intérieur de toi.
Puis quand c'est motivation intrinsèque,
c'est que chaque victoire c'est un
carburant pour continuer, pas une fin en
soi.
Euh le problème n'est pas euh que tu es
trop ambitieux, c'est que tu as la
mauvaise sorte d'ambition. fait de
décider justement quel type d'ampion to
tu joues mauvais jeu. Ça on revient un
peu à finit infinite game qu'on a euh
regarder
dans une autre vidéo de peut-être une
semaine de semaines.
la différente les deux jeux fini, jeu
infini jeu fini tu joues pour gagner
donc pour avoir l'objectif pour avoir
ton diplôme pour avoir du du cash peu
importe puis je infini tu joues pour
continuer de de jouer donc tuas des
règles qui évoluent tu as pas de fin
d'infini des joueurs des joueurs connus
et inconnus l'objectif c'est pas de
battre contre les autres joueurs, c'est
d'avancer avec eux apprendre avec eux
bâtir avec eux l'objectif c'est de
rester dans le jeu toute sa vie de
grandir de contribuer de bâtir quelque
chose de plus grand que toi
Donc par exemple si tu bâtis, je sais
pas moi, tu pass une entreprise mais
plus pour que tous les gens dans
l'entreprise euh se sentent bien, qu'il
a une belle vie, que tout le monde soit
heureux, qu' a une culture d'entreprise,
tu bâtis des relations avec ton tes tes
des gens, tes clients, ton staff, peu
importe, ton business, il est humain.
tu b quelque chose pour que tout le
monde soit heureux autant à l'interne
que à l'externe de ton entreprise. Tout
le monde soit heureux au sein
d'entreprise. Donc de te dire je
construis quelque chose que je veux
encore faire dans 20 ans. Pas juste euh
je dois atteindre un million puis je
vais me lever, je vais lever des fonds,
je vais sortir de la business. Tu sais,
pas avoir des objectifs comme ça. Je
veux exit avec 20 millions puis tout ça
parce que là tu quand tu vas
l'atteindre, tu vas attendre un vide
puis
tu seras pas épanoui autant que tu le
penses.
Euh l'entrepreneuriat c'est un jeu
infini mais souvent c'est il est joué en
mode fini. Donc ce que la culture te dit
c'est ça, c'est atteindre atteint le
niveau puis ex ta business, atteindre
tel ch d'affaire, décroche le
financement. Un coup tu as atteint 1
million de financement là tu es good
lance-toi réussi puis après ça
retire-toi. C'est c'est comme
l'objectif, c'est le mindstone le plus
le plus important, c'est genre exit,
fais du gros cach puis tout ça après ça
une maison pu tu sais c'est comme tu vas
jamais satisfait quand tu vises comme ça
pu ce que ça crée tu es chroniquement en
mode je suis pas encore arrivé ou pire j
suis arrivé puis maintenant je fais quoi
puis les deux états font mal les deux
sont les impasses fait que les deux
tu atteins ce niveau-là puis tu es pas
heureux il y a un vide dans toi parce
que tu dis m' comblé c vide là avec de
quoi à l'extérieur au final tout était à
l'intérieur de toi euh de Simon Senc les
joueurs infinis entrent dans les jeux
finis sans être définis
donc c'est là qu'on va voir la
différence
pas
on
comme des je fin comme des
pas là. C'est what ? Non, c'est même pas
là. OK, on va on va aller
tranquillement. On va aller au même
ride, peu importe, on va revenir
làdessus. Mais
ça, il y a une autre partie qu'on
voulait embarquer, c'est sur le dire oui
compulsivement. Donc de dire oui parce
que tu as peur de manquer quelque chose,
de manquer de manquer thing ou de faire
juger comme étant pas assez ou de
décevoir puis quand tu donnes des oui
qui sont qui étaient des noms à la base
mais que tuas dit oui pour te plier euh
ben c'est un nom à quelque chose d'autre
qui compte plus qui compte vraiment pour
toi.
Euh c'est pas en faisant plus qu'on
réussit mais c'est en faisant moins,
mieux et avec intention qu'on réussit.
Euh tes objectifs, ça c'est des side
quest. Ta vie c'est la même quest. Donc
d'où le point de
embarquer dans les jeux finis avec un
mindset infini.
Je m'explique donc deavoir une side
quest qui est décroché un premier
client, un side quest qui s'est lancé un
produit side quest atteindre 100000 de
chiffre d'affire euh 100000 par mois peu
importe tu sais des quest mais la même
quest c'est c'est qui tu deviens en
faisant ça c'est quoi tu construis en
faisant ça c'est pourquoi tu joues c'est
quoi ton c'est quoi la la chose que tu
bâtis plus grand que toi tu sais c'est
ça qui donne du sens
à tes side quest tu sais pourquoi
Pourquoi tu dans un baccalauréat ?
Baccalauréat, une maîtrise, peu importe.
Puis euh la différence les deux, il y en
a un qui va embarquer euh qui est en
mode c'est sa quête principale, c'est un
jeu fini. Il va faire la MBA pour avoir
le titre quand avoir le titre
là tu sais là m' avoir un MBA je pour
mettre mon link puis
là m' bien
tu fais 2 ans tu travailles quand même
tu travailles puis tu au moment tu mets
ton MBE
what's next tandis que l'autre M quest
je infini ton mind c'est je veux me
développer au maximum Je veux qu'on soit
des gars plus grand que moi. fait que là
au lieu de juste être à mindset, je vais
avoir mon titre,
tu focuses sur sur le process de e je
vais embarquer, je je vais essayer
d'apprendre le plus de monde possible,
apprendre comment qu'il pensent, créer
des relations, euh créer des projets,
embarquer dans des comités, vraiment
m'épanouir en mode j'essaie d'apprendre
le plus possible, retirer le plus
possible de tout ça, apprendre à me
connaître, voir explorer des des
projets, des types de personnes pour
voir avec qui que je connecte le plus.
Puis on grandit au travers de ça. Vous
voyez la différence ? C'est pas
c'est pas genre
ton c'est rendre à X.
C'est je me rends j'utilise le le le
véhicule de je me rends à X
mais tout le long du du trajet, j'essaie
d'apprendre, j'essaie d'évoluer, de te
poser des questions sur qui tu deviens,
que tu grandis et cetera.
Euh
puis que ouais, ici c marqué mais que
chaque échec devient
si tu es en mode jeu fini, tes échecs
que tu vis,
ça va être des fins ça va être des
crises existentielles de te poser des
questions e je à bonne place, je
c'est ça, je à bonne place e mais s va
pas pu tu sais tu plus en lié vers le
négatif tandis que quand tu es en m en
mindset jeu infini c'est comme tu vis
les difficultés tu es comme ah nice
let's go tu sais genre oui c'est t mais
j'apprends à me connaître j'apprend à
évoluer puis genre prochaine fois genre
m'avoir grandi puis je vais être prêt tu
sais
fait tu vois les choses beaucoup plus
dézoomé tu sais tu as un mindset qui est
beaucoup plus dézoomé plus macro au lieu
de micro tu sais
donc
une question à poser c'est si personne
voyait jamais tes chiffres, ton
LinkedIn, ton compte de banque, ta
maison, ton ch ta blonde, whatever.
Est-ce que tu ferais les choses comme ça
? Si tu dis oui, c'est parfait, ça veut
dire que tu es tu construis pour les
bonnes raisons.
Mais si tu dis non, il y a un problème
d' tu fais ça pour les autres, pour
plaire aux autres, pour montrer aux
autres que
l'ambition problème, c'est la nature de
l'ambition. Si c'est pour prouver
quelque chose
validation externe une ligne d'arrivée
peu importe tu es pas bonne place mais
c'est pour construire quelque chose donc
s toi c'est là tu dois aller c'est plus
un feeling c'est plus une intuition
c'est plus
ta récompense c'est plus les
apprentissages que tu vas faire pendant
le processation
plus durable
là tu risques d'être heure plus
longtemps toute ta vie à ce mindset là
puis que tes échecs que tu vis c'est des
apprentissages. C'est facile à dire,
c'est difficile à appliquer à difficile
à à main
avoir ce réflexe le mental
mais d'essayer vraiment de dézoomer.
dézoomer sa vie, je pense que c'est une
des cl
euh ça fait un petit des petits use case
de même là par exemple une situation qui
est tu rates ton pitch devant tes devant
des juges, peu importe puis euh tu ton
pitch si c'était pour si tu étais en
mindset égo
là tu vas dire crise d'identité e je
suis pas à bonne place remise en
question totale de j'étais pas bon là n
na puis là tu sais encore dans le
négatif mais si c'est pour construire
quelque chose
Tu vas prendre ça comme de la data, tu
sais. Tu vas te dire "Ah, OK, ça s'est
pas bien passé. Euh, je me suis pas
senti bien, j'étais pas à l'aise sur
scène. OK, c'est bon, tu sais. C'est OK,
est-ce que bon, est-ce que je est-ce que
je l'ai fait pour les bonnes raisons ?
Est-ce que tu sais là, tu apprends sur
toi-même en posant toutes ces questions
là, sors de la data sur toi-même, tu
sais. C'est comme e j'apprends à me
connaître, tu sais. C'est quand même fou
là, tu sais. Tu es né avec
un corps avec des avec un un cerveau des
capacités, des skills, des choses qui
sont plus facile pour toi. qui tu te
connais pas, tu sais pas tu es qui tu
sais pas c'est quoi tuaimes dans vie là
il y a peut-être bien les affaires que
tu aimes dans vie mais que tu as jamais
découvert parce que tuas jamais testé tu
sais
fait en étant dans ce mindset là de je
veux construire quelque chose dont
apprendre à me connaître mais toutes les
erreurs toutes les choses qui t'arrivent
dans ta vie
tu le prends comme e j'apprends à me
connaître j'apprends à voir comment que
je réagis à J'apprends à
mieux me
saisir, à mieux savoir qu'est-ce que
j'aime dans vie pour que la suite de ta
vie soit plus en lignée avec tes
valeurs, avec ce que tu veux faire dans
vie. Euh
c'est pas un appel à baisser tes
standards. Donc ça c'est pas c'est pas
pas toute le fait de a fais moins
l'ambition c'est mauvais ralenti. C'est
pas ça pas tout. C'est choisis juste le
bon tit d'ambition,
joue le bon jeu fait que joue mindset
infini au lieu de jeu fini et les mêmes
actions produi des résultats
complètement différents parce que ta
relation avec ces actionsl sera
différente. Donc au lieu de focus sur le
résultat, tu vas focus sur le process
d'apprentissage puis de ce que tu bâtis.
L'entrepreneur, c'est pas un sprint vers
une ligne d'arrivée, c'est un jardin. Tu
n'arrêtes jamais de le construire, tu
choisis quoi faire pousser. Donc
tu essais des choses, tu grandis puis tu
alimentes toutes ces ces projets-là, ces
ces apprentissages, ces valeurs là, ces
relations là, tu es fait grandir, tu es
fait pousser tout c'est tu tu bâtis
quelque chose qui est plus grand que
toi, tu sais, puis tu apprécies ce
process là tel qu'il est.
Euh, trois raisons posé pour la la
confusion. Donc first, c'est elle qu'on
a posé tantôt. Est-ce que je ferais ça
si personne allait jamais le voir ?
Alors moi par exemple, c'est ça que je
fais en ce moment avec les vidéos
YouTube. Je fais pas de montage, je fais
pas peu importe c'est quoi qui est bien
basic
mais j'ess des affaires. J'ess des
affaires. J'essie de partager ce que
j'apprends. Puis même s'il y a pas
personne qui le voit, c'est pas grave.
Moi, je vise le long terme, je vise de
s'il y a des gens qui ont qui vont
tomber sur mes vidéos, il vont tomber
sur mes vidéos puis on va connecter de
même
puis ça en mode vraiment je découvre, je
découvre, j'essaie des affaires, il y a
pas de montage ou très peu de montage
puis je teste puis j'apprends à me
connaître au travers de ça. Puis c'est
ça la quête, c'est pas atteindre 100000
abonnés, c'est pas atteindre 1 million,
100 millions, tu sais, c'est juste je bâ
ça sur le long terme.
Je si ça peut motiver des gens
de voir quelqu'un qui qui essaie de quoi
puis qui se fout un peu du résultat
puis il fait juste se fier plus au
process,
ben écoute, c'est parfait.
Euh puis une autre question, c'est quand
j'imagine avoir atteint ça, qu'est-ce
qui vient après dans ma tête ? Tu sais,
est-ce que si tu dis mon objectif
atteint 1 million de ch d'affaires, bah
imagine-toi atteindre ce 1 million là.
Bon, demain matin, tu l'as, on fait quoi
d'autre ?
OK, là peut-être bien, il faudrait que
j' plus de monde. OK, là prochain serait
engagé de doubler le le nombre de
personnes qui est là parce que là après
ça, on voudrait aller euh genre euh
aller taper le 5 millions. OK. Là, c'est
ça, tu sais, tu déjà là, tu es déjà en
train de penser à OK, c'est quoi les
prochains objectifs ? Tu es même pas
satisfait de ça, tu sais. Fait que tu te
rends compte de comment c'est effèr cet
objectif là.
Euh, est-ce que je construis quelque
chose ou est-ce que je prouve quelque
chose ?
Naturellement, vous comprendrez que si
c'est pour prouver quelque chose, tu es
pas sa bonne traque puis que tu vas
passer ta vie
insatisfait parce qu'il y a tout le
temps quelqu'un qui va être plus riche
que toi. Tu sais, j'ai écouté une vidéo
de Yomy Yumy Denzel qui parlait
euh
il parlait de GMK,
en tout cas gros gars qui qui bras des
centaines de millions. Puis il disait
que même lui à Monaco, il y a du monde
que lui euh des centaines de millions,
c'est des pinotes là, c'est rien.
Tu es tout le temps quelun qui plus
riche que toi puis c'est inévitable.
Fa qu' écoute,
mais pas ça comme objectif, tu sais
parce que tu vas être pas heureux toute
ta vie. tu vas rat race de
travailler plus pour avoir le plus gros
poste, avoir le avoir le meilleur poste
à meilleur business puis
ou avoir la plus grosse business, avoir
plein de business puis faire du gros
cash exit puis tu sais tu vas tout le
temps être là-dedans.
Ben, c'est la meilleure manière de se
brûler, tu sais.
Euh les mêmes actions, une relation
complètement différentes, on a parlé un
peu. Mais tu sais avant le reframe, tu
sais, chaque refus ça se remise en
question de e je suis vraiment je suis
pas bon à ça. Puis tu sais être dans
négatif tandis que l'autre ça va être tu
veux juste ajuster ton gap, tu sais. Tu
vas ajuster, tu vas apprendre sur
toi-même. OK, prochaine fois on va faire
ça puis on va juste apprendre tu sais
puis c'est juste de la data de plus.
Donc c'est juste du positif au final, tu
sais.
Euh donc l'ambion c'est pas le problème,
c'est l'obsession à la destination qui
est le problème.
Le journey is le business.
Donc l'aventure c'est vraiment
c'est ce qui doit être qui doit
alimenter, évoluer, apprendre
puis apprendre sur toi-même même dans
tes échecs
puis apprécier le fait de grandir au
travers de ça.
Donc c'est un framework complet. Donc tu
vas atteindre tes objectifs,
construis-les pour toi.
Donc vraiment un rappel à just
te fixes des objectifs, fais pas juste
focus sur tes objectifs. focus sur
comment tu vas grandir au travers de ça,
ce que tu vas déléguer
au travers de ça,
ce que tu vas
l'ambiance toi, tes relations que tu vas
bâtir au travers de ça.
Ouais, mais c'est sûr que c'est pas
facile à à mettre en place. Je suis
parfaitement conscient que c'est euh
c'est pas évident,
mais
je pense juste dans être conscient,
juste d'être conscient de
OK, j'ai pas vu j'ai pas eu une bonne
journée aujourd'hui, mais comme e
dézoome dézoome ton
ta vision,
apprécie le process en mode OK, mauvaise
journée. Qu'est-ce que j'apprends de ça
?
Qu'est-ce que je peux faire mieux la
prochaine fois ? puis d'être heureux
d'avoir eu cette mauvaise journée-là
parce que ça va te permettre d'en avoir
10 autres des meilleures journées que
ça. 20 tu sais toute la ta vie il va
être meilleur parce que tu as vécu cette
journélà qui était moins bonne tu as
fait des erreurs. Mais le fait d'être en
mindset positif, axé sur l'évolution
puis de grandir puis d'apprécier le fait
de grandir,
ben ta vie va être beaucoup plus
heureuse, beaucoup plus épanouissante
pour que justement à la fin de ta vie
quand tu vas être sur ton sur ton lit de
mort puis tu vas repenser à ta vie
ben de te dire que tu as vécu ta vie à
toi. Tu as vécu ta vie à toi. Je la
centré sin ça va être
Ouais. Donc euh de
te dire que tu as vécu ta vie à toi, tu
as tu as pas subi euh ce que la société
voulait que tu fasses à tuas pas
tu as vu tu as fait tes choix à toi, tu
sais, puis tu as apprécié ta vie comment
tu l'as vécu puis euh
ouais écoutez, j'étais un peu fatigué
mais arrê la vidéo là, ça fait comme
deux fois que je la filme fait que je
pour ça que dire que là je suis je suis
Je plus fatigué mais
encore une fois c'est les apprentissages
puis le fait de refilmer cette vidéo là
ben j'apprends
de mes erreurs que j'ai faites don de
pas cliquer sur le démute quand j'ai
record mon écran,
mais
j'apprends puis j'évolue puis j'apprends
sur moi-même
puis euh
mais c'est beau la Il faut juste essayer
des affaires puis de pas être stick sur
les objectifs sinon c'est sûr que tu vas
être malheureux.
Donc
je peux revenir sur les trois questions
juste pour que tes ailles
en tête.
Donc
est-ce que je est-ce que je ferais ça si
personne allait jamais le voir quand
j'imagine avoir atteint un objectif ?
Qu'est-ce qui vient après dans ta tête ?
Puis est-ce que je construis quelque
chose ou je prouve quelque chose ?
Donc sur ce, bonne réflexion. Au revoir.
What ? Attends, je peux OK. Oui,